hi I'm Ryan it's pretty late right now
but I promised I would watch the trailer
for the purge anarchy I don't know [ __ ]
about this second one I'm assuming that
takes place on the purge the purge the
first one first one kind of sucked first
one was like oh you got this great
[ __ ] concept and then it like does
[ __ ] home invasion [ __ ] with it it
was awful real letdown real letdown
great concept though great [ __ ]
concept I've had sex with that concept
let me just think about it you could do
whatever you want
anything goes this one night of the year
a judge a home invasion movie man they
could have like bought hookers they
could have done a bunch of cocaine they
could have sniffed cocaine out of
hookers like Leonardo Capri on the wolf
of Wall Street all that [ __ ] in the wolf
of Wall Street would have been legal on
the purge the purge could have been a
lot more interesting except they just
turned to some stupid killer thing it's
better than everyone just needs to kill
no one wants to do petty crimes like
robbed the 99-cent store or something
all right time to get purged Anarchy
sign Anarchy over no it's fun now that
is some good acting
Oh No nothing out of the purge man not
the night of the purge because it's the
purge kill them
you know how he goes Oh lock and loaded
the [ __ ]
it's the choker game from Batman Beyond
it's got cool
and hockey all you need is a little NRT
God God
how will you purge black hookers people
know me they know that's my first answer
okay it's true you know honestly like
didn't really scare me or pull me in
that much but what I will say is it
looks like it could take a more
interesting concept it doesn't look like
it's more solid than the first one but I
like the idea of exploring more of the
outside world rather than what's going
on this one home while the world has a
more interesting thing going on so yeah
it's kind of cool that you know they're
taking it out to the streets this time
[ __ ] training day out there man
for those two lead actors man they seem
like they're shitty [ __ ] actors like
horror movies like to do that like take
your concept and they put a big actor in
the first one and then they're gonna go
you know what second third one people
don't give a [ __ ] about the actors let's
throw some shitty actors in there that's
what they've done they're damn
good-looking couple
there's the purge initiate a threesome
warning in five seconds experience
energy although I don't need the purge
to do that